ATR是非常有力的艦船。
在乎全的系统是控制或是用力的力量。
因此,它是重要的,
为了解駕駛的系统。
Hi, my name is Magnar Nordahl, I am an ATR Typewriting Instructor and Captain
and this channel is all about aviation.
In this video I will give a short introduction to the electrical systems in ATR aircraft.
You may find this useful when you watch videos about other systems
or when you watch my coming videos about accident investigations.
这些节目会在这些时间的节目会有几个小时
但要得到全解析的电脑系统
你必须学习近几个时刻的电脑系统
我们开始有些解析
电脑系统是电脑系统一路向前
电脑系统是由于电脑系统
它是通常用在低-voltage applications和電腦的機器,像是電腦。
當設定在一台 metal frame,像是電腦,
只需要一台 cable,因為電腦的電腦可以接受電腦的電腦。
電腦也有利用能量的電腦。
AC是是电源,是电源,电源是电源。
是电源是叫电源,电源是叫电源,电源是电源。
在电源电源是电源是400 Hz,或者是400次的电源。
电源电源電源电源是电源电源通过电源,电源电源在电源中。
to convert DC into AC you use an inverter also called a static inverter
to convert AC into DC you use a rectifier ATR calls it transformer rectifier unit or TRU
a bus or a bus bar is a strip made of conductive metal such as copper or aluminium
Bus是用来传到电力量的力量到的系统。ATI aircraft有很多BusBars,sed to distribute electric power to the systems.ATR aircraft have many bus bars, mainly to provide redundancy.Here is an example from the ATR.
The negative terminal of the main battery is attached to the airframe.
The positive terminal is attached to the hot main battery bus,
which enables the attached systems to be powered when the battery switch is off.
每個系統有一個操控器和
有些電源接近的接近接近
接近是電源接近的電源
它是開啟的當選擇的電源
主機的電源會不會營造電源
電源接近的電源
現在我們看看整個系統
我們開始由器材, 他們都拿雜用電池
電池的缸電池最左上方, 可營電池的缸電池和 DC駿電池
一些東西出品這些缸電池電池是
從業電池的煤、酥浴營使用器, 火營營運動、 時薔導
開啟動電池,使用器材讓您開始動電池雜用電池的穴充電池
電池電池減電池的缸電池含電池
多指揮快速速器 或濃烈電流
在駕駛的一些配置等电源上面是 预备暴光的速度
VHF1 也是电源线制 能放到相机的速度
其他的设法 甚至是 预备似空的速度
также電源线飾 也许多指揮的电源
电源自动电源线台 电源线央 电源线
ILS receiver number one. The ACE standby bus is powered via inverter number one and supplies the
standby pitot tube heat, the flaps position indicator. In other words, the standby bus bars
enable you to fly an instrument approach and LAN. Furthermore, the main battery powers the ground
它供用了一部電汽車輛機器, 它供用了一部電汽車輛機器,
它們是燃燃燃機器, 它們是燃燃機器,
這部電汽車輛機器並沒有燃燃機器.
我們有兩 DC燃燃機器, 它們是輪到其他輛機器,
它們供給了28V電汽車輛機器,
它們燃燃機器, 它們燃燃機器, 它們燃燃機器,
在最高的61.5rpm
它是一種燃料
DC generator 1它是一種DCBS1是一的二 main busbars有些 system powered by DCBS1
是駕即带扭物,
駕即带扭物,
电台链器,
DCBS1支援的駕駛产充充充充輸電器
和駕駛及 inversor1
1.DC Gen 2 supplies DC Bus 2, the other main bus. And pay attention now, because this bus
bar powers the automatic function of the hydraulic auxiliary pump and the automatic function of the
rudder travel limit unit, the TLU. There have been some incidents where the crew missed those items
而未能保持擁有控制的操控後,
DZBUS2也能保持主機器,
而且能保持其他部份的部份,
以及2BUS2,
而是3部份不重要的部份,
DZBUS1和2BUS1,
提供光線,
電腦部門,
但不及早上,
感情及流量的燥煤
各擅自操機能
可否在一流量的螢幕上
另一方可以使用霤
BUS-Ti-Contactor
BTC operates自動
操作制止
但可選擇手法
Isole
The two inverters supply constant frequency AC power to AC bus 1 and AC bus 2 respectively
Each bus bar is in fact two bus bars one supplying 26V and the other 115V
The AC bus bar supplies several avionics
As mentioned earlier, inverter 1 also supplies the AC standby bus
在場地的失禁, 通常的汽車輛, 通常汽車輛的汽車輛
保持一汽車輛的汽車輛
當汽車輛電源是接觸電源, 通常汽車輛電源是通常汽車輛電源
而汽車輛電源是電源電源電源通常汽車輛電源通常汽車輛電源
而是它看起來在平常的工程中但我們還未完成還有一個更加多電源一個是這個電源力水平
是叫做電源溝電源源因為
是因為它的溝電源源源源源源而入手機
主機
對於監控能量活動 400Hz
電源源源源源源源源分子
AZWILE frequency system operates from 341 to 488 Hz
depending on the propeller rotation speed called NP
the voltage is 115 or 200
the ACWILE system power systems that are needed for taxi and flight
for example taxi lights, landing lights, hydraulic pumps and ice protection
另一方面,我們也有有一個電源,
另用冷氣喻客的地方,
可以提供氣流用冷氣,
而且在這裡的冷氣喻客,
我們可以自主機的冷氣喻客接近
而是自主機的電源有同樣的能量。
像一輛電源開機,
另一輛電源開機,
兩輛電源開機主機主機主機主機,
但這個情況下,
在加速電源開機中,
因为它的电源是缺乏的飓风力
ATR500和600V有一个Transformer Rectify Unit
它是电源由 ACWI bus2
在连续失去两个电源电源
TRU会提供 DCEBUS, DCEBUS,和 both standby busbars
这确实确保持电子不被拆除
而是需要的预防伤伤或 ETOPS
ATR船和 TRU可以批准了120分 ETOPS
这就是这次的时间
短时间不介意识到所有的细节
希望你明白基本上的理解
請支持這個頻道按讚,訂閱和分享給朋友們
謝謝收看,樂觀看
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目